حيث قالت وسائل اعلام الروسيه والصحافيون
وعسكريون روس ان المدفعيه الروسيه الحقت
خسائر كبيره باللواء 61 الاوكرانيه خارجه
مدينه سوليدار الخسائر البشريه في الصفوف
القوات الاوكرانيه بنحو الثلاثه مئه قتيل
روس صورا قالوا انها لعمليه تدمير عمليات
تابعه للواء الاوكراني 61 مساء
من جهه قال المتحدث باسم قياده العمليات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في المنطقه الشرقيه
سير هيك شيرفاتي ان محور سوليدار باخ موت
هو المحور الاكثر سخونه على امتداده خط
الجبهات بين الجيشين الاوكراني والروسي
واضاف ان الجيش الاوكرانيه مستمر في
الدفاع عن مواقع في مدينه سوليدار ويلحق
الخسائر في صفوف قوه فاجنر في بخمود تبث
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه صورا قالت انها
لتصدي قواتها لمحاولته تسلل الناروسيه
واكدت ان جنودها يحافظون على مواقعهم في
المدينه رغم كل الهجمات الروسيه